كاكي كاكي كا كي كا ***  البَطُّوطَةْ المُضْحِكَةْ
بِالسِّبَاحَةْ مُحَنَّكَةْ ***   كاكاكاكاكا
بَطَّةْ تُحِبُ البَطْبَطَةْ ***    فِي السًّعَاَدَةْ مُفْرِطَةْ
لِلأمُورِ مُبَسِطَةْ ***     كاكاكاكاكا
بَطَّةْ حُلْوَةْ مُؤَدَبَةْ  ***     بِالمَنْزِلِ مُرَتَبَةْ
لِلجَمِيعِ مُحَبَبَةْ  ***     كاكاكاكاكا
كاكي كاكي كاكي كا ***  البَطُّوطَةْ المُضْحِكَةْ
بِالنِّظَامْ مُتَمَسِكَةْ
لَا تَكْذِبْ لاَ لِلصِدْقِ تَقُولْ
وَوَاجِبُهَا دَوْمًا مَحْلُولْ
وَوَجْهُهَا نَضِرٌ مَغْسُولْ
بِالبِرْكَةِ طُولَ اليَوْمِ تَعُومْ
كاكي كاكي كا كي كا  *** البَطُّوطَةْ المُضْحِكَةْ
بِالسِّبَاحَةْ مُحَنَّكَةْ ***  كاكاكاكاكا
بَطَّةْ تُحِبُّ أُخْتَهَا  *** تُعْطِيهَا أَلْعَابَهَا
أَيْضًا نَحْنُ نُحِبُهَا  *** كاكاكاكاكا
بَطَّةْ ولَدَيْهَا أَصْحَابْ ***  تَسْتَقْبِلُهُمْ بِالتِرْحَابْ
وَبِوِدٍ تَسْأَلُ مَنْ غَابْ ***   كاكاكاكا كا
كاكي كاكي كاكي كا ***  البطوطة المضحكة
للصَدَاقَةْ مُدْرِكَةْ
جِيرَانُ البَطَّةِ كُوكُو الدِّيِكْ
ودَجَاجَةْ وثَلاَثَةُ صِيصَانْ
وبِخُلقٍ مَحْمُودٍ وَسُلُوكْ
تَتَعَامَلُ مَعَ كُلِّ الجِيِرَانْ
كاكي كاكي كا كي كا *** البَطُّوطَةْ المُضْحِكَةْ
بِالسِّبَاحَةْ مُحَنَّكَةْ *** كاكاكاكاكا
الدِّيِكُ يَحترمها  والدَّجَاجَةْ تُحِبَهَا
والصِّيصَانُ مِثْلُهَا  كاكاكاكاكا
كاكي كاكي كاكي كا ***  بَطَّةْ حُلْوَةْ مُضْحِكَةْ
مَا أَحَدٌ مِنْهَا شَكَا ***  كاكاكاكاكا
كاكي كاكي كا كي كا ***   البَطُّوطَةْ المُضْحِكَةْ
مَا أَحَدٌ مِنْهَا شَكَا